tell me when you had to tell your
children your younger children in
particular about the Big C word how is
here do it I didn't want my kids to be
scared but we were advised by the nurses
in my oncologist office right away tell
the kids family secrets are dangerous
you can have trust issues later in life
the unknown is much scarier than the
known they're gonna send something tell
them and I mean they kind of glazed over
a little bit I think it's a pretty big
concept what would you say the best
lesson cancer has come to teach you the
power of support the healing power of
support one of the big discoveries I
think I made is that I think I mean it's
my personal opinion but I think there's
a huge disconnect between all these
people going through cancer and I want
to try to get them together I know it's
a very very big ambition I know I
believe you're gonna do it you gotta be
I believe you you gotta try I can see
how this new calling has energized you
really big dreams you can't stuff a big
life into a little dream I get big big
big dreams just like you do I know you I
know you where are they now all new
saturday ten nine central
you